- The triangle shape freaks me out
because it's like Illuminati.
(techno music)
- What's up guys?
My name is Hal.
I make videos here at BuzzFeed,
in New York.
And today we are trying the
Taco Bell chicken nugget.
In my head, Taco Bell
and chicken nuggets don't go together
but they're here.
So, I'm gonna go around the office
and see what our
Buzzfeed staffers have to say.
(techno music)
- I'm all about this idea.
Love Taco Bell.
Love chicken nuggets.
- They kind of look like Doritos
so it's kind of sketchy.
- The nice, like meat triangle I have here
gonna dip it into this yellow goop
and I'm pretty excited about it.
Let's eat this food?
- Do I have to do this?
Yes, okay.
- Okay.
- It tastes like those
dinosaur nuggets that
you get as a little kid.
- Mmm, I'm into it.
I think it's good.
- The flavor is very,
chicken nuggety, you know?
- I don't like this, at all.
Sorry.
- It's really cheesy.
I don't know if I like it with cheese.
Like a cheese sauce.
- It's the classic like,
fake cheese.
Which you can't go wrong with.
- With the nacho cheese,
it tastes like a chicken nugget nacho.
Which is,
it's a euphoric experience.
I'll have to say.
- And the cheese confuses me.
- I don't like that it's
in the shape of a triangle
because it reminds me of a Dorito.
So then, when I'm putting it in my mouth
I really wanna taste,
like nacho cheese Doritos
or something good.
- The shape is interesting.
I think it just to like separate itself
from the competition.
- Tastes like what it looks like.
Which is triangle shaped meat.
Kinda get what you expect out of it.
- I like that it's thin.
So, I wouldn't feel as bad if I ate
like, a million of them.
- Oh, I would rank this well above
other chicken nuggets, I think.
But then again, I
love Taco Bell.
- Compared to other chicken nuggets,
I've had in the past,
I would say it's about on par
around McDonald's,
around that level.
I think is,
right around there.
- Um, yeah.
I'm just, I'm really disturbed
all around by this nugget.
- It tastes like a chicken triangle.
It tastes not of this Earth.
- I would say it's pretty comparable to
all the other chicken nuggets.
They all kinda taste the same to me.
- My mouth is very happy right now
and I would definitely buy this
at Taco Bell.
- I feel like if I was drunk
and I just wanted some chicken nuggets,
I would do it.
- I honestly thought it was gonna
not taste good at all
because they're not really
known for chicken nuggets.
- 10 out of 10 would recommend this.
- The only time I would see myself
eating this, is if
I was peer pressured at my office
to do this on camera.
- I can't wait to see
other shapes of chicken.
Maybe a chicken rhombus
a chicken
isosceles triangle.
This is the equilateral triangle,
right here.
I'd like to see an
isosceles maybe some day.
Pretty exciting times.